Поліцейська форма замість одягу для карате.
В поліції  знадобилися мої фізичні навички
в плані якоїсь сили.
Більше ніяких прийомів кіокушинкай –
дуже контактного і жорсткого стилю.
А натомість – кайданки, сльозогінний газ, на крайній випадок - пістолет "Форт".
- У Вас стріляли?
- Ні.
- А Ви стріляли?
- Ні. З ножем намагалися, але не напали. Відверталася.
затримували, вчасно реагували.
12-разова чемпіонка України і триразова чемпіонка і призерка Європи
з кіокушинкай–карате Анастасія Мельничук
ще в 2015-му дуже хотіла піти в нову поліцію.
Але змогла це зробити, лише коли їй виповнилося 21, у 2017-му.
Наразі Анастасії 24-ри, і за 3 роки вона виросла до молодшого лейтенанта.
Завдання Анастасії та ії напарника Олександра Ясури –
патрулювання доволі неспокійних вулиць та дворів Оболонського району.
Вони помічають цих чоловіків, які чомусь у спеку одягнуті в теплі куртки.
Патрульних насторожує і їхня поведінка.
Вони почали дуже нервувати, побачивши здалеку поліцейську машину.
Так реагувати, це трошки ненормально.
Бігати-убігати кудись, щоб Вас затримували…
Ці сирени лунають не просто так.
І не просто так патрульні розвели чоловіків у різні боки.
Один з них, ймовірно, у розшуку, за підозрою у вбивстві.
А поки цю інформацію перевіряють,
Анастасія і Олександр намагаються продовжувати бесіду.
Розшук не підтверджується
Проте життю поліцейських несподівано загрожує небезпека.
Маска є? Маску надягай!
Маску надягніть!
Чоловік це виконує не одразу. І ця усна вимога –
чи не єдиний важіль впливу патрульних на людей, які хворі на туберкульоз
і яких на вулицях чомусь не меншає.
Питання  в тому, що ми нічого з ними не можемо зробити.
На законодавчому рівні вони мають право ходити.
Якщо вони на стаціонарі, то їх іноді відпускають додому по своїх справах.
Часто на викликах патрульні працюють разом з лікарями швидкої.
Як от у цьому випадку – перехожі повідомили про чоловіка,
який лежить на узбіччі мосту.
Штани поряд лежать. Голий він був.
Ще нічого не сказав! Ні слова.
Патрульні і медики мають надати допомогу та з'ясувати,
чому він має вигляд наче його зняли з операційного столу.
І чому він ледь стоїть на ногах?
Що і де робили з цим чоловіком?
Купа запитань і, відповідно, різних сценаріїв.
Анастасія намагається з’ясувати якомога більше деталей і встановити його особу.
- Ви чуєте мене? Звідки ви?
- З Києва.
- А звати як?
- Серега.
- А прізвище яке? А скільки Сергію років?
- 38.
Патрульні можуть інфікуватися, стати об'єктами словесної агресії
чи навіть фізичного нападу.
Це ризики, з якими мають справу патрульні.
Анастасія Мельничук зізнається, що майже закохана у свою роботу.
І не збирається здаватися, навіть якщо колеги та колежанки навколо неї
поступово уходять від такого адреналіну патрульної служби.
За час, поки я працюю - 3 роки, Багато дівчат перевелося на більш спокійну роботу -
в відділ адмінпрактики, в саме управління.
А ви хочете?
Поки що ні. Я не бачу себе в сидячій роботі.
Експатрульній з  Одеси Зої Мельник
робота у новій поліції теж дуже подобалася.
Вона прийшла працювати ще у 2015-му.
Проте вже через рік вона розчаруваласяу реформі.
У Фейсбуці жінка розповідала про повернення нової поліції до схем старої міліції,
коли замість допомоги людям
поліцейські займаються зароблянням коштів для свого керівництва
Були екіпажі, які у нас назвали "летючими голландцями".
Вони виїжджали, коли їм зручно.
Брали взагалі машину, так би мовити, в оренду.
Ми всі один одного знаємо і знаємо, хто, наприклад, бере хабарі або не бере.
І ми побачили, що з приходом нового керівництва всі,
хто був помічений у нехороших речах,
раптово пішли на підвищення,
але  при цьому почалася війна з неугодними.
Зоя зіткнулася зі справжнім булінгом на роботі.
фактично вижили. За те, що вона повідомляла про зловживання пресі.
Наразі жінка у суді оскаржує наказ про своє звільнення.
Схожа історія - і у експатрульного з Києва Антона Снєжкова.
Його теж звільнили за його критику дій керівництва.
Він працював у Печерському районі столиці,
де правопорушники – це здебільшого високопосадовці.
Мене збила машина однієї дуже серйозної людини з ГПУ.
Збила його службова машина. Я її зупинив, затримав,
все оформив відповідно до закону, викликав слідчих.
Мого напарника шпиталізували.
Чим закінчилося? 680-т. Ні, навіть 425 грн штрафу!
Просто за те, що їхав по зустрічній.
А те, що нас збила машина, ну, нічого страшного. Ти ж поліцейський!
Антон намагався протидіяти корупції та зловживанням.
Але то інформація з його боді-камери кудись зникала,
то служба моніторингу ніяк не реагувала на його повідомлення.
Нова поліція, упевнений Антон, поки не перемогла стару міліцію.
Зараз скажу таку штуку, знову на мене всі образяться...
Якщо раніше була поліція, в якій працювали міліціонери,
то тепер це "мусарка", в якій ще залишаються працювати поліцейські.
Вони всі ентузіасти, якщо працюють, ризикуючи своїм життям і здоров'ям.
Хоча реформа поліції триває вже кілька років,
держава ще не починала турбуватися про самих поліцейських.
Медичного страхування немає, повного КАСКО на поліцейські авто - теж немає.
Патрульні лікуються власним коштом, самі виплачують і збитки,
якщо під час служби пошкодили інші автомобілі.
Зарплата для життя замала – максимум 14-15 тисяч гривень.
І це, враховуючи усі ризики професії.
Чинні поліцейські, з якими спілкувалась DW, погоджувалися з тим,
що їхня робота має оплачуватися гідноі що вони мають бути застраховані.
Проте вони кажуть, що принаймні з корупцією з боку керівництва поки не стикалися.
І якщо їм пропонують хабарі, то вони, як правило, цих людей затримують.
Єдине, що справді викликає в них невдоволення -
це Кримінальний кодекс, який так досі і не змінили.
Командир екіпажу Олександр Ясура  прийшов до поліції у 2015-му.
Каже, досі чекає, коли ж Верховна Рада посилить відповідальність водіїв,
які стають винуватцями ДТП в стані алкогольного та наркотичного сп’яніння.
Обидва патрульні також чекають, коли ж реформа охопить
усі правоохоронні органи, прокуратури та суди.
Дуже багато скасовується через суди
протоколів про алкогольне сп’яніння водіїв.
Також багато
будемо казати так -  кримінальних справ закривається
через  якісь нюанси пов’язані із затриманнями,
можливо, з судами, доказами.
Кількість поранених та загиблих від ДТП - занадто висока  ціна,
яку сплачує суспільство за відсутність швидких змін на усіх рівнях,
згодна Анастасія Мельничук.
Ця робота, зізнається вона, дуже виснажує морально і фізично.
Але, попри усі негаразди в усієї правоохоронної системі України,
вона з колегою не готові відмовитися від служби в патрульній поліції,
що, як вони вважають, робить усе можливе, аби допомагати людям.
До того ж, вони сподіваються, що пауза в реформуванні
правоохоронної системи України не буде вічною.